І чули всі, що німці знищують єврейську національність.
Донька Бетя в гетто в Немирові.
У сім’ї вирішили, що врятуємо.
Не знали, зранку прокинемося чи не прокинемося. Будемо живі чи не будемо.
Я, Назаренко Василь Мусійович, Праведник народів світу.
І наша сім’я з другої половини серпня 1941 року по 7 січня 1944 року рятувала сім’ю єврейської національності, матір і доньку.
Є таке село Війтівці Липевицького району Вінницької області.
Там я народився, там у школу пішов до війни.
Війна почалася 22 червня, а нас окупували війська, лінія фронту дійшла десь в кінці липня.
Радіо не було, світла не було, нічого не було. Але чутки ходили серед людей.
І чули всі, що німці знищують єврейську національність.
Євреї почали втікати, йти геть з постійних місць проживання.
Заходили в село, не тільки наше, просили поїсти і так далі.
І ось у другій половині серпня 1941 року жінка в кінці дня приходить, маленька така, ось тітонька Анюта.
І просить заночувати - заходь. Вона разом з нами повечеряла, а далі ніч є ніч.
А зранку встала і звернулася до батька: "Мусій Васильович, врятуйте життя!"
Батько сам рішень не приймав, зібрав усю сім’ю і каже: "Так і так, що будемо робити?".
Всі проголосували за те, щоб врятувати.
Але тітка Анюта все хвилювалася, все ходить та плаче.
То що ж таке? Донька Бетя в гетто в Немирові.
Це від нас 18-20 кілометрів. У сім’ї вирішили, що врятуємо.
Тепер вона розповіла про Бетю, описала її зовнішній вигляд. І моя сестра старша пішла туди, в Немирів.
А охорони тоді ще не було, про нашу хитрість, про партизанів тоді ще ніхто не був поінформований.
Ну, і побачила її, впізнала за зовнішністю, описаною матір’ю. Вона підходить: "Ти Бетя? - Бетя".
Була дуже щемлива зустріч, я її пам’ятую, цю зустріч.
І сльози, і радість. І ось так от, ось так 2 з половиною роки разом і жили.
Ми знали, тому що якісь чутки доходили, десь там німецька пропаганда велася,
що якщо хтось рятує тих людей, то будуть розстріляні, а місце зрівняють із землею.
Це ми знали, тому лягали спати і не знали, зранку прокинемося чи не прокинемося. Будемо живі чи не будемо.
Всі розуміли це і ходили, як то кажуть, по вістрю ножа.
І два з половиною роки сусіди ні спереду, ні ззаду, ні справа, ні зліва - ніхто не знав.
Ми це розуміли, і вони розуміли. Тому що німців не так боялися, як своїх, поліцаїв там, зі свого оточення, тому що різні люди в селі.
Щойно хтось з’являвся у хвіртці, собака гавкав, мама через вікно хоп, сусідка йде…
А якщо хтось чужий ішов, були відпрацьовані певні знаки.
І по знаку вони хоп, якщо щось таке, вони йшли, в річку, в поле поруч йшли.
Моє завдання, оскільки я був наймолодший у сім’ї, було не розбовкати і нікому нічого не казати, але робити розвідку в селі.
Коли в 1944 році 7 січня нас звільнила Червона армія, увесь народ при в’їзді танкових підрозділів у село…
Люди вийшли із самогонкою, із салом, всі зустрічали наших воїнів, увесь люд зібрався.
А в селі ж знають, хто живе на тому кінці, а хто на цьому, скільки в кого дітей, скільки курей, все знають.
А ці дві нові, тітка Анюта з Бетею вийшли. А це хто? Що за люди?
А хтось там відповідає: "Це ті люди, що Мусій рятував". Значить, мабуть, хтось таки знав.
Вони пішли з військами, і все.
Ввлаштувалися у Вінниці.
А коли отримали квартиру, вони написали нам у село лист.
Одним словом, відновився зв'язок. І він тривав цей зв'язок до кінця життя тітки Анюти і до кінця життя Беті.
Такого максимум тиждень не бувало, щоб ми з нею не розмовляли.
Вона називала мене своїм братом, сестер називала сестрами, і були вдячні.
Я пишаюся цим, пишаюся своїми батьками, собою пишаюся і своєю сім’єю.
Мене це надихає і підносить.
Бо я свій обов’язок в житті виконав, такий героїчний обов’язок, брав участь у порятунку людей.
Для мене це гордість.
Праведники народів світу - це герої, тому що якщо людина знаходиться на фронті,
у неї є зброя в руках, вона захищає своє життя і захищає чиєсь життя.
А у праведників світу окрім власної совісті більше не було нічого…